we'll so I'll be getting ready to head
out to Europe got it George or up Europe
Europe you know he's [ __ ] speaking at
accents what's that video you sent me
the other week of that Ukrainian girl
just going off on a watered down crazy
wait I got to play this I got to play it
oh I said it - yeah the RPP yeah the
peep the penis the People's Republic of
the penis palladium we have not died oh
we can talk about this [ __ ] don't we
already talked about that yeah
[ __ ] Jesus I gotta find this
[ __ ] video okay here nope not that
one you got some bad [ __ ] this is like
some model that yeah here it is she's
responding to some DM she got about how
she keeps her skin so clear okay an
innocent question just a fair question
and she just people that keep asking me
what the hell do I keep my skin clear
oh no sugar prodding going through I was
just gonna describe this yeah you'll
really need to see it so she's going
through her fridge right now and she's
just grabbing like the foods that she's
referring to one at a time and going no
sugar protein yeah grabbing like her and
they're all like Whole Foods there's a
grass berries and like it's just like
organic bread and [ __ ] no added sugar
[Music]
no palm oil no sugar ingredients peanuts
[Music]
my candy you see listen other candy hey
my father's on Japan days morning my
soda my either soda or tea want some Jim
a hundred percent from fruit no sugar
100 percent fruit guess what it's got no
sugar no cane sugar pepper is on your
face comes from the inside stop Aiden
[ __ ] and sugar want some ice cream
well guess what high in protein no sugar
and if anyone will dare to tell me that
those things are tasteless bad news for
you because that just means you've been
eating so much [ __ ] since you were born
that actual nature food it's tasteless
to you because you've been eating
everything packed this [ __ ] sugar
since were but trust me little baby
angels as soon as your body get all
freedom all the crap you've been eating
or you're sending this food is gonna
taste like heaven your skin is gonna
look healthy and glow when you're just
gonna be smart
cuz honestly I have no [ __ ] idea what
the hell to expect from your skin if you
treat your body like a trash can where
people don't have an obsession with
[ __ ] fast food where we go to the
next street and we get actual real fruit
vegetables fruits from little grannies
that just picked it up from their
gardens that they raised okay
we got it we got it lady coast 20 pounds
team your [ __ ] dawn
fried don't do it steam it boil it eat
it raw dawn fry it and [ __ ] Tana oil
what's good like that the hitting [ __ ]
style filming things jogar
yeah just [ __ ] pound slamming things
noting and dollars steam it your [ __ ] no
oil
this is punching
Oh
oil steam the [ __ ] steam it crash it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] oh my god the throw a [ __ ]
towel down on this [ __ ] no so dud water
I want to parody that [ __ ] just talking
about how some of you asked how I make
my face look like [ __ ] let me show you
this is over my fridge it's like Taco
Bell and just crunch rapping just across
the [ __ ] room Crunchwrap supreme cool
ranch Dorito put it in your [ __ ]
mouth I have no idea what to expect out
of your skin if you're eating healthy
food raspberry chocolate in peace Taco
Bell put it in your [ __ ] mouth trust
me little baby once you eat enough [ __ ]
your face will finally look normal it
will taste like heaven as do though I
was condescending video ever she's like
hey I'm a model let me show you how what
I do yeah it has rust me little babies
yeah and she the worst part was was that
she's like she's like you've been eating
[ __ ] your whole [ __ ] life it's like
yeah but that's like half half of it
it's like
not their fault yeah parents been
feeding the [ __ ] sugar since they
were a kid and that dog it's like it's
like also yeah maybe it all like her
[ __ ] attitude yeah you have clear
skin but maybe you're also a [ __ ]
model yeah dick not everyone is built
like you you [ __ ] [ __ ] you think
if we all just magically get clear skin
we just now we're just clear skin Oompa
Loompas we're still [ __ ] we're still
built the way we're built
yes it's most of you have been eating so
much [ __ ] since you were born must be so
nice but sorry we don't have like
grannies if arms next door to us there's
not there's I don't know a single farm
around where I live there's not one
granny no there's those Bristol Farms
Bristol Farms yeah it's a grocery store
exactly Bristol Farms and there's um
auntie you know granny Auntie Anne's
Pretzels yeah [ __ ] I don't think you
should break out put the pretzel in your
[ __ ] mouth once I'm gene punching
everything bun Singh the jam once I'm
Jim smashes the [ __ ] bottle on the
counter she's so [ __ ] rude dude beer
drinking alcohol shove it in your mouth
suck it down pop tart eat it eat more
eat whole box of pop tart Cheesecake eat
it
cheesecake eat it mint chip ice cream
breakfast Jimmy John overload with meat
and cheese after breakfast Thai tea with
boba snack suck it down suck it
put it in your [ __ ] face Jessie might
sub hold it in your ass that's not a
flex